[Musique]
merci Jean-François hon de nous
accompagné pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu de la Meurth et
Moselle membre du groupe les
républicains rapporteur général du
budget et la nuit fut courte on va en
parler puisque le Sénat a débuté hier
l'examen du budget on va y revenir
longuement avec vous d'abord on l'a vu
dans le journal ellisabeth borne a
conclu le Congrès des maères hier et
elle a annoncé quelques mesures pour
donner au maire le pouvoir d'agir c'est
ce qu'elle leur a dit on aura notamment
une loi de décentralisation sur le
logement qui sera présenté au printemps
prochain et une enveloppe pour mieux
indemniser les élus des petites communes
rurales est-ce qu'elle a suffisamment
répondu aux attentes je ne sais pas mais
il y a une chose qui m'a frappé c'est
finalement l'espèce de froideur avec
laquelle les mesures ont été accueillies
par les maires les maires en fait ils
sont en attente d'une vraie confiance
d'une complicité d'une compréhension
d'un soutien
où les collectivités l'État pourrait
avancer de concert parce que finalement
le cap est donné aujourd'hui je pense
que la France est est mal menée la notre
cohésion nationale la cohésion sociale
la cohésion territoriale il faut en fait
il faut mettre beaucoup plus de cœur il
faut de l'affect quand vous êtes maire
que ce soit d'une ville moyenne d'une
grande ville ou des petites communes moi
je viens d'un village de 50 habitants
vous imaginez c'est une tête d'épingle
dans une mele de foin et bien il faut
apporter un un supplément de soi-même et
et même beaucoup d'engagement et ce
que ce que je constate c'est cette
finalement cette rupture ce ce manque de
confiance et c'est un peu c'est non pas
désolant mais c'est regrettable de voir
que les annonces qui ont été faites les
maires doivent se dire il est bientôt
temps pourquoi pourquoi avoir attendu
voilà c'est un peu l'état d'esprit qu'on
ressent aujourd'hui dans la France des
territoires je l'ai entendu en tous les
cas pour ma part au cours de l'été en
faisant ma campagne sénatoriale parmi
les annonces d'éisabeth borne il y en a
qui vont s'ajouter au budget que vous
êtes en train de d'examiner notamment
cette enveloppe de 100 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour la dotation globale
de fonctionnement qui est la principale
dotation de l'État aux collectivités en
plus des 220 millions déjà prévu vous
soutenez cette mesure bah elle en fait
elle elle répond euh comment dirais-je à
l'uroprè quasiment à ce qu'on attendait
puisque j'ai fait moi-même une
proposition et un amendement que j'avais
préparé pour améliorer de 70 millions et
en cohésion au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale on avait prévu de faire 70
et 30 c'est-à-dire 100 voilà c'est un
élément de réponse ça démontre au moins
une chose c'est que ce que nous Allion
proposé ce que nous demandions
correspond aussi à des besoins mais je
je le redis je crois que il va falloir
aussi faire en sorte que chaque euro
investi soit un euro utile et efficace
il y a ben non il y a aujourd'hui
beaucoup trop de gaspillage on vient de
terminer la revue des dépenses la revue
budgétaire que d'enveloppe budgétaire
avec soit des réserves alors ça sert à
rien de je dirais de bodybuilder les
enveloppe budgétaire il faut les
calibrer le mieux possible et puis
parfois on a des bonne surprise donc on
a besoin de moins bien il faut tout de
suite rendre l'argent et puis parfois on
l'a vu avec les événements que ce soit
sur l'énergie avec l'envolet des prix à
un moment ou avec la guerre en Ukraine
et il faut des moyens supplémentaires il
faut les mobiliser c'est ça aujourd'hui
nous devons gérer de manière beaucoup
plus responsable parce que un état qui
gère de manière responsable c'est un
état qui va entraîner le pays et je le
redis les collectivités territoriales
qui sont souvent montré du doigt vous
avez de l'argent vous avez du mou vous
devriez non mais que l'État balaye
devant sa porte mais vous avez entendu
les les maires ils se plainent notamment
d'une rupture de lien fiscal après la la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation
est-ce que pour vous il faut créer un
nouvel impôt pour les communes alors je
vais vous dire il faudrait mais
aujourd'hui la difficulté je alors je
l'ai vécu en direct tout au long de
cette campagne sénatoriale quand vous
dites l'attente des maires c'est de
retrouver du lien entre le territoire et
puis l'action que vous menez quand
l'État vous prive de ressources fiscales
d'abord il vous démotive puis finalement
il vous prend en porte à faux puisque
vous n'avez pas la main vous devez
attendre je dis pas la manne céleste
mais c'est presque ça on se dit est-ce
que l'État sera bien au rendez-vous de
dotation c'est un mot d'ailleurs comment
dirais-je qu'il faut prendre pour ce
qu'il représente ça n'est pas indu c'est
la compensation de ce que l'État a pris
en vous privant des impôts en fait c'est
c'est aller à
cont-temps plus vous retirez de capacité
au territoire à à être motivé à chercher
des solutions à innover pour accueillir
des entreprises pour construire des
parcours résidentiels pour les habitants
pour faire évoluer son territoire quand
vous attendez comme seul levier la
décision verticale évidemment ça ne peut
créer que des déceptions parce que on a
une multitude de situations et
aujourd'hui notre France elle a besoin
de vivre elle a besoin d'être pétillante
dynamique d'entreprendre il faut
retrouver recréer un climat de confiance
on va parler du budget puisque le Sénat
a entamé hier l'examen de ce budget
votre objectif faire des économies on va
en parler tout de suite avec notre
journaliste Quentin
[Musique]
calmer bonjour Quentin bonourian bonjour
jean-françoison Quentin on va parler de
ces premières heures de séance dans
quelques instants mais d'abord un mot
Jean-François hon parce que votre nuit a
été très courte et on voudrait que vous
nous expliquer pourquoi c'est ce qu'on
appelle la nuit de la mort ce qui s'est
passé cette nuit pour vous oui enfin
c'est c'est effectivement la formule
retenue pour quelle raison bah c'est
simple vous avez vu nous avons comment
dirais-je l'ouverture avec la discussion
générale sur le prjet de loi de finances
qui a eu lieu hier après-midi voilà hier
après-midi vers 18h 18h30 euh j'ai
quitté comment dirais-je la séance
publique qui se poursuivait sur un autre
thème et à partir de ce moment-là
puisque nous avons tous les amendements
de la première partie hein sur le volet
dépenses de l'État d'abord aujourd'hui
on on est on se dit mais combien il va y
avoir d'amendement alors il y a il y a 5
ans il y avait en gros 600 amendements
hier on en avait
2253 voà vous avez passé une nuit très
est courte parce que vous avez passé
toute la nuit à éplucher cette casse
d'amendement c'est bien ça ce qui s'est
passé c'est ça en fait
l'objectif initial c'est toujours de
voir tous les amendements alors c'est la
nuit s'est terminé à enfin le travail
s'est terminé à 5h du matin ça n'est pas
fini donc il va
falloir d'abord on a ouvert le dimanche
pour travailler et puis on va essayer
aussi de réguler le dispositif mais
chaque chaque amendement est visé par
les équipes et il y a toujours des
arbitrages ça n'est d'abord ça n'est pas
fini et parfois tant que je n'ai pas
rendu le l'avis qui va être donné en
commission ça ça peut changer voilà et
Quentin vous avez suivi la séance hier
c'est une longue séquence budgétaire qui
SV voilà c'est le marathon budgétaire
comme chaque autonne au Parlement c'est
le projet de we finance pour 2024 qui a
été lancé hier on le comprend
Jean-François hon après le vote sur le
budget de la CC ça ça sétait tenu mardi
en séance effectivement c'est une longue
séquence qui sououvre 3 semaines de
débat un vote final prévu pour le 12
décembre dans ce budget adopté avec 493
à l'Assemblée nationale tout le monde
cherche à faire des économies le
gouvernement quitable sur 16 milliards
d'économies notamment avec la fin des
boucliers énergétique et un déficit qui
passerait ainsi de 4,9 % du PIB en 2023
à 4,4 % en 2024 écoutez donc hier à la
tribune Bruno Le Maire le ministre de
l'Économie nous tiendrons donc l'obj de
4,4 % 2024 je mis eng gage mais nous
tiendrons aussi notre objectif de
revenir sous les 3 % de déficit en 2027
nous le devons à nos compatriotes nous
le devons également à nos partenaires
européens nous devons donc inscrire le
sérieux budgétaire dans la durée avec
calme clarté et détermination nous
poursuivrons donc les revues de dépenses
et toutes les dépenses publiques seront
soumises à cette évaluation et à cette
revue
la droite s'alarme sur l'état des
finances publiques Jean-François Husson
vous avez parlé de finances qui sont
dans le rouge cramoisie c'est votre
expression écoutez une autre sénatrice
Christine Lavarde hier encore lors de la
DG alors que le gouvernement a peiné à
trouver des économies pour 2024 appelant
les parlementaires à en faire 1 milliard
de propositions supplémentaires 12
milliards d'euros doivent être trouvés
pour 2025 pour tenir la trajectoire de
réduction du déficit public tout au long
de la discussion de ce PLF nous
l'occasion de vous démontrer qu'il est
possible de faire plus de 5 milliards
d'économies dès 2024 alors Jean-François
hon que dire de ce budget est-ce que
déjà il est insincère vous avez dit au
ministre je ne vois pas d'économie
quasiment toutes lesémission budgétaire
Contin continu d'être à la hausse c'est
ce que vous aviez dit en commission des
finances qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
benah je je confirme d'ailleurs j'ai
posé des questions j'ai bien écouté le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
qui n'est pas resté d'ailleurs pour
longuement pour la ou il s'est vite
éclipsé hier oui oui c'est c'est je le
dis ça a agacé certains de vos collègues
ou ça agace et puis c'est dommage et je
pense que ça n'est pas respectueux
d'abord du Sénat et puis je vais dire un
mot de la situation dans laquelle on est
on est dans une situation où il n'y a eu
aucun débat en séance publique à
l'Assemblée
nationale si je 493 à cause du 493 et
j'ai envie de dire ça bricole en
commission
nous arrivons au Sénat nous proposons
nous nous connaissons le contexte bien
évidemment je ne me fais pas d'illusion
mais on en appelle la majorité
sénatoriale les sénateurs en appelle à
la responsabilité du gouvernement il ne
faudra pas balayer d'un revers de main
les 3 semaines de débat que nous allons
avoir au Sénat sur la trajectoire
budgétaire on vise les 3 % de déficit en
2027 c'est atteignable avec la courbe
qui est en train de prendre le déficit
publ j'ai de gros doutes on entendait
voilà Christine lavard qui parlait de 12
milliards à faire l'année prochaine va
être un Murard 12 milliards l'année
prochaine cette année il y a une dérive
supplémentaire il y a une dérive
supplémentaire de 5 milliards 7 qui se
prépare ça n'est pas raisonnable nous
allons nous proposer des économies et
les économies évidemment quand vous
proposez moins de dépenses il faut faire
des choix et bien nous en proposerons
parce que que c'est l'intérêt supérieur
de notre pays on va venir sur les
économies mais la France a été épinglée
il y a quelques jours par Bruxelles pour
ces dépenses excessives la Commission
européenne lui demande de prendre les
mesures nécessaires pour respecter les
limites européennes pour vous c'est
sévère ou c'est justifié ça va finir par
arriver de toute façon au-delà alors
c'est inquiétant parce que toute
dégradation de la situation budgétaire
et financière nous allons la payer
lourdement plus de 40 milliards
d'intérêts de la dette de
remboursement cette année nous allons
passer à plus de 80 milliards en 2027 à
cause des marchés qui se tendent aussi
mais quand vous avez une dette
importante évidemment c'est plus
difficile d'abord il y a un retournement
des marchés mais fallait pas espérer
avoir des taux d'intérêt négatif
éternellement enfin un peu de sérieux on
va parler des économies justement
Quentin comment va évoluer le texte dans
les prochaines semaines parmi les pistes
avancées par la majorité de la droite et
du centre il y a par exemple le délai de
carence des fonctionnaires portés à 3
jours cette mesure pourrait rapporter
220 millions d'euros si elle est adopté
on va voir les autres changements qui
pourraent intervenir dans les prochaines
semaines d'examen en tout cas des
mesures qui vont faire débat on parlait
de ce délai de carence de 3 jours pour
les fonctionnaire il y a aussi une aide
au département que vous voulez porter à
100 millions d'euros on avvez vu que
c'était une demande lors du congrès des
départements de France à Strasbourg une
taxes pour les plateformes de streaming
de musique en ligne on voit aussi un
débat qui va revenir notamment avec vos
alliés centristes sur l'opportunité ou
non d'une taxation du des super profits
des entreprises et enfin un débat autour
du prix minimum unitaire pour l'alcool
que dire de toutes ces modifications où
allez-vous trouver les 4 à 5 milliards
d'euros que vous promettez on les trouve
dans différents domaines on va les
trouver par exemple beaucoup dans euh la
formation sur le le la formation
professionnelle par exemple dans le
budget de l'Éducation nationale nous
avons aujourd'hui 1 milliard pour
l'année 2023 1illard 300 millions qui
sont prévus pour la formation des
enseignants 1er et second degré public
et privé nous nous proposons 700
millions d'euros d'économie pour quelle
raison on a regardé depuis plusieurs
années vous avez des budgets beaucoup
trop important à l'heure actuelle fin
octobre sur les crédits 2023 40 %
seulement des crédits sont consommés qui
peut considérer que c'est une bonne
prévision qui peut accepter que ce soit
raisonnable non nous allons faire en
sorte que sur l'apprentissage on on
garde la performance mais il y aura des
propositions d'efforts de réduction
d'enveloppe nous allons également faire
en sorte de commencer à cibler les les
efforts qui sont faits sur l'électricité
pour les particuliers pour les ménages
qui sont dans les haut revenus nous
allons améliorer le soutien et l'appui
pour les ménages les moins aisés et pour
les classes moyennes et pour les classes
moyennes ces classes moyennes qu'est-ce
qu'ell demandent aujourd'hui le respect
du travail qu'on libère le travail et le
temps de travail pour qu'elles puisse
profiter parce qu'ell aussi d'abord
parfois elles ont besoin de gagner plus
elles sont elles ont envie de donner
plus à leur pays Bruno Le Maire annoncé
hier qu'il souhaitait réduire la durée
d'un indemnisation des chômeurs de plus
de 55 ans c'est une bonne piste c'est
enfin je n'en peux plus de ces mesures
intempestive annoncé à tour de bras je
fais tout j'annonce je ne fais pas
j'annonce à nouveau la décentralisation
ça fait 18 mois qu'on nous balade
d'annonce en annonce nous on se prépare
au Sénat on a une réforme qui a été
travaillé pour poser les bases donc
enfin souvent le président jardarcher le
dit au travail n'attendons pas on est
mobilisé
ouais depuis 2020 on voit qu'il y a un
débat qui vous oppose à vos alliés
centristes ici au Sénat sur
l'opportunité d'une taxation des super
profits des entreprises qui ont profité
de la crise ce débat va revenir à
l'occasion de ce PLF pourquoi est-ce que
vous Z toujours opposé bah il il y a une
vision
différente d'abord les super profits
comment dirais-je on va regarder deux
secteurs l'énergie et
puis le les containers oui transport de
marchandise transp de marchandis le
marché sur les transports de
marchandises il y a eu lié à la crise
une envolée à un moment elle n'a pas
duré longtemps la question de se dire et
si vous faisiez des efforts et si vous
redonniez une partie de ces efforts un
peu exceptionnels ça n'est pas lié à
votre uniquement en tous les cas votre
politique commerciale c'est c'est un
concours de circonstances je dois dire
que des efforts ont été faits notamment
euh vis-à-vis des des territoires
insulaires qu'on appelle souvent les les
les oututres mèes les ultramarins avec
CMA CGM nous les avions enfin je les
avais même reçu le le le Président
Directeur Général rodolp sad et puis
c'est également dans les les producteurs
les fournisseurs d'énergie on a bien vu
là aussi que les la contraction du
marché et l'emboler des prix à mérité
qu'il ait des efforts faut-il pour
autant des mesures euh qui soit par trop
contraignante qui qui qui enserre et
cadenace je ne crois pas donc nous
allons mais nous allons trouver les
points d'équilibre vous en avez un peu
parlé Jean-François hon Quentin on va
revenir sur les conditions de l'examen
de ce projet de loi de finance qui ont
été contesté voilà à droite comme à
gauche on dénonce effectivement les
effets d'utilisation du 493 à
l'Assemblée nationale le texte du
Gouvernement faisait 60 articles
initialement au bout de quelques jours
le gouvernement a déclenché le 493 à
l'Assemblée et a ajouté 175 nouveaux art
le en reprenant par-ci par là des
amendements venus des députés de quoi
irriter les sénateurs qui se retrouvent
avec un texte dont beaucoup de mesures
n'ont pas fait l'objet d'une étude
d'impact ou d'un avis du Conseil d'État
c'est ce que vous avez redit hier en
séance comme les communistes écoutez
Pascal salv il a essayé lui de faire
voter une motion de renvoi dans
l'après-midi écoutez-le pourquoi on fait
cette question préalable parce que quoi
qu'on va décider
ici le retour à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est le même dispos positif qui va être
mis en place celui qui a fait qu'à
175 articles ajoutés sans le débat de
nos collègues à l'Assemblée nationale et
qui vont être arbitrés avec un 493 à la
fin donc voilà c'est c'est c'est pas
qu'une humeur ou une sorte d'opposition
pour s'opposer c'est voilà les dés sont
pipés les dés sont pipés monsieur Husson
vous reprendriez cette expression non
mais je je je la reprends pas simplement
je le redis j'appelle le gouvernement
à regarder la réalité en face les yeux
ouverts et à ouvrir je dirais les bras
et surtout à
proposer les conditions d'un dialogue
constructif en intégrant un certain
nombre de propositions qui vont sortir
des débats sénatoriax voilà ne pas
balayer du 493 et d'un revers de la main
tout ce qui aura été
ajouté au je pense que si le
gouvernement je dirais bomble Tor et
veut user de sa majorité relative au
niveau national je lui prédis desès
lendemain difficile en juin dernier
Gérard Larchet président du Sénat mtait
en garde contre des risques
d'accidentologie lors de l'examen de ce
budget et il évoquait une possible
censure si le gouvernement ne
s'employait pas à redresser les finances
publiques est-ce qu'aujourd'hui au vu du
texte vous demandez aux députés d'aller
jusque là non d'abord je je je je
souhaite je le redis que le débat a lieu
de manière euh posé constructive au
Sénat je le redis c'est important nous
allons envoyer de nombreux messages mais
c'est pas parler ou pérorer et puis je
dirais le vent la fraîcheur la nuit
emporte tout ça non c'est parce que nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une démocratie
qui est fragilisée la cohésion je l'ai
dit la cohésion de notre pays mais de
manière plus large regardez un peu
l'état de l'Europe les tensions euh
internationale la situation géopolitique
la situation je pense impose le sérieux
et le travail et donc nous au Sénat nous
avons décidé de travailler le
gouvernement doit à nos côtés travailler
et doit s'inspirer des travaux c'est sa
grande
responsabilité je le dis euh c'est pour
ça que la l'attitude de Bruno Le Maire
hier c'est une forme de désinvolture
quand il est parti de la séance sans
écouter toutes les prises de parole de
la discussion générale enfin voilà il y
a euh ait discours et ensuite il il est
immédiatement parti i en plus la moitié
du discours on était beaucoup se sont
demandé s'il y avait déjà le début d'une
campagne une chose après l'autre la
responsabilité quand on est au Sénat et
qu'on vient présenter l'enjeu d'une d'un
projet de loi de finances et d'un budget
c'est de d'abord après après avoir après
s'est exprimé c'est au moins par respect
d'écouter les Orates t les orateurs de
chaque groupe politique on suivra
évidemment l'examen de ce budget
jusqu'au 12 décembre he Quentin vous
l'avez rappelé on en parlera tous les
jours dans cette émission merci Quentin
tout à l'heure merci on va passer du PLF
à l'AMF et on évoquera la
DGF mer qutin pour terminer on voit
l'actualité dans votre département
jean-fance on retrouve Michel dem
bonjour Michel merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous directeur départemental de
l'Est Républicain en Meur et Moisel et
dans vos pages Michel vous allez nous
parler de cette manifestation
d'agriculteur hier à Nancy oui bonjour
jean-fançois vous avez dit deux fois
déjà depuis tout à l'heure que cohésion
nationale et est mal menée l'agriculture
semble très mal menée aussi en ce moment
donc hier Anan 160 tracteurs ont
manifesté contre le trop plein de
paperass contre le trop plein de
contrainte et le trop peu de
considération alors la question elle est
simple c'est quoi la solution pour les
agriculteurs de France pour demain et
bien c'est de convenir et de fixer un
cap et des orientations en écoutant et
en travaillant mieux avec tous les
agriculteurs aujourd'hui lui on dit on
parle de la ferme France un nos
collègues le sénateur duplom a produit
un rapport pour tracer les lignes et les
perspectives la l'agriculture française
a été longtemps un de nos flurons elle
était souvent la première des
agricultures en Europe ça n'est plus le
cas parce que parce que de trop de
contraintes parce que des
atermoiements parce que un manque de
choix et
d'orientation travailler ensemble
aujourd'hui quand vous êtes dans nos
campagnes l'état d'esprit des
agriculteurs ressemble malheureusement
trop à celui des maires ils ne sentent
plus le même soutien et la même
confiance ils sont montrés du doigt
quand ils sont dans leur champ en été
qu'il récoltent le grain évidemment les
machines hier comme aujourd'hui font du
bruit mais aujourd'hui il faudrait
qu'ils arrêtent à 19h pour le bien-être
et le calme des campagnes
quand il y a il y a des épisodes
difficiles que ce soit aujourd'hui
tempête grêle inondation maladie sur les
céréales les difficultés d'écoulement et
de prix de marché pour l'élevage le la
la violence parfois de certaines
population à l'endroit des éleveurs qui
sont dans une une condition difficile
vous prenez dans l'élevage l'élevage
laitier aujourd'hui nous allons d'ici
peu nous allons manquer de production
laitière retrouvons un cap fixons des
orientations soyons fi de notre terre la
terre nourriissière celle cette
agriculture qui a été avec le charbon et
l'acier un des deux piliers de la
construction européenne c'est tellement
beau c'est tellement ambitieux c'est ça
qu'il faut construire et il faut arrêter
effectivement d'ajouter des contraintes
qui viennent les unes aux autres
s'ajouter et finalement qui qui amènne
une forme de dégoût et qui détourne les
jeunes pour la reprise des exploitations
agricoles c'est autour de ces enjeux
qu'il faut travailler et notre
agriculture évidemment elle a aussi
besoin d'être accompagné et soutenu dans
les perspectives d'une meilleure prise
en compte de l'environnement
international et des sujets
environnementaux il faut donc aider
accompagner assurer la transition et non
pas multiplier les contraintes et la
réglementation mais ce que fait ce que
fait la France que fait Marc Phen
suffisamment il y a notamment l'histoire
du glyphosate là récemment où l'Union
européenne a prolongé 10 ans l'autoris
la France s abstenue lors de ce vote à
eu raison sur le glyphosate je vais vous
dire on a aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de produit dit phytosanitaire qui
servent à quoi servent-ils enfin c'est
c'est méconnaître le le je dirais
l'amour de la terre et le travail de
l'agriculteur l'agriculteur il a besoin
parfois bah de soigner je dirais ces ces
récoltes à venir pour leur permettre de
de lutter contre les maladies dit sur je
prends juste un exemple sur le
glyphosate aujourd'hui par exemple il
est parfaitement compatible avec une
forme d'agriculture qui s'appelle
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
où justement on protège les sols pour
qu'ils retrouent leur richesse donc là
encore peut-être moins de de de revers
de manche qui balai comme ça d'un coup
toute la table non je crois qu'il faut
regarder il faut accompagner notre
agriculture elle a 1 et un visage et
donc là merci Jean-François hon merci
d'abord Michel demau d'avoir été avec
nous on regarde la Une de l'Est
Républicain dans son édition de Nancy
c'est Thomas Pesquet la fusée Thomas
Pesquet à Nancy à la Une de l'Est
Républicain merci beaucoup Michel
d'avoir été avec nous et merci
Jean-François hon merci d'être venu
d'autant qu'on l'a dit la nué était
courte merci beaucoup d'être venu nous
voir dans 20 minut